[Music]
we still have institutions that are too
big to fail and don't let anybody tell
you otherwise
because all the stuff they say about how
they can now fail without causing
collateral harm is not true
these are institutions that are bigger
than any institution by asset size not
Apple not Facebook not anybody is as big
as say JPMorgan Chase they're all
connected together in a big knot they're
all together at the house of cards that
you know all works while it works and
when the next time something really
starts rattling it is going to be scary
misconduct pays to the people across the
board lower level and higher level and
as a society we we kind of become a
little bit helpless to to prevent it all
we can do is we can send a corporation
to jail and then we have not enough
means to show criminality of individuals
because it's all very diffuse and very
deniable and and difficult to prove in
court or whatever or we don't spend the
resources on on these kinds of you know
white-collar persecutions in the
corporate context who knows or the
combination of reasons but bottom line
is the consequences for individuals are
usually minimal even when a lot of
wrongdoing is done in a corporate
context
you have people who are angry with the
rigged system and yet they don't
completely understand the ways in which
the system is really rigged and then
they are prone to being directed to be
angry at the wrong targets at the media
at immigrants at certain countries and
without actually looking at some of the
issues that are really
corroding and and and distorting and
corrupting the democracy that we have
here
I like to give examples of safety of you
know buildings or airplanes or bridges
or whatever here you know the public
demand safety it doesn't need to know
the details of the engineering to kind
of demand that there is a system that
creates you know safe building safe
bridges safe safe flight and there will
be immediate consequences for everybody
involved and we wouldn't even know who's
responsible when there doesn't work in
the financial system it's virtually the
opposite you know the recklessness is
just spread out and there's no direct
line between what somebody does and a
little bit of excessive rest that they
they take or the extra loan they make or
not make and in sort of the the outcomes
and then it's very easy for the public
to get completely confused about about
what's what's going on what the public
needs is to see the problem first
because recognizing the problem is the
first step to solving it
[Music]